there's a culture of learning that
develops in in a collaborative
environment where there's exchange and
choice and genuine human interaction and
to participate in that evolving culture
of the classroom is is a privilege I
really woke up to ideas I would say as a
10th grader when I went to a private
school in greenwich connecticut and met
a student of ludwig von mises who was
teaching a high school economics class
she was great friends with Leonard read
and the Tina and Percy graves of the
foundation for economic education and so
my roots really came out of that
environment and it's where I discovered
that I love to think that I love ideas
and I love freedom but it was really my
encounter with the Austrian tradition of
economics especially Mises and Hayek
that I think turned me to pedagogy
reading the use of knowledge and society
you can really read that not as a piece
of economics or even just the political
philosophy but as a work of pedagogy he
is talking about how knowledge is
distributed amongst unique individuals
and how not all knowledge comes from a
single source and that piece really
inspired me to learn more about the
learning process how human beings learn
I love this analogy that I thought of
when reading the mystery of capital by
Hernando de Soto Hernando de Soto makes
a very startling claim in that book he
asks the question who owns most of the
world's capital and you're thinking
about you know fortune 500 companies or
Bill Gates or whoever and he says that
no actually the poor on most of the
world's capital but the problem with
that capital is that doesn't have an
economic life it's it's dead capital and
I really think that that's the situation
in most classrooms around the world
whether you're talking about secondary
school or whether you're talking about
undergraduate or even graduate programs
you have rooms filled with dead
intellectual capital and most students
experience formal education as an
audience member and as an audience
member you're just still quiet and if
you can pay attention and if you can
somehow incorporate someone else's
understanding into yours by listening
you're in good shape but for most of us
that really doesn't address most of our
learning capacity I've had great
experiences learning about economics but
a lot of them didn't take place in a
classroom they took place in long car
ride discussions at reading groups that
we went to it cafes and there's great
enthusiasm and a lot of dialogue and and
sometimes when you're sitting in in a
classroom listening to a professor talk
about some theory that you haven't yet
connected to it's hard to be as
enthusiastic about these ideas and and
really get them in the same way a lot of
people that come out with the classical
liberal tradition who are trying to
teach ideas of Liberty they have a
magnificent understanding of the
complexity of the social world and the
density for preserving that environment
for choice in exchange and the freedom
to explore and the freedom to make
mistakes but when they come into the
classroom many of them teach as if
they're castro in charge of an island
and all of those ideas those high a key
and ideas of spontaneous order gets set
aside what really inspires me about
teaching at UF em is that they are
changing that we're moving out of class
rooms like this one and into rooms where
the student is at the center and where
the faculty can be learning that their
students are the most important resource
that they have to teach the students
like Hayek says have knowledge that's
unique to them it's dispersed amongst
all of them so you can make that
intellectual capital alive by offering
environments where students are choosing
where they are interacting where they're
exchanging or you can put them in rooms
like this where they are still silent
and passive my background is in
Montessori education I had a real
passion for it and still have a real
passion for the ideas of Maria
Montessori who saw the classroom as in
Hayek in terms of spontaneous order
where it was the result of human action
or the students actions if you will but
not necessarily a human design I see an
awful lot of what u of m is doing as an
extension of some of the fundamental
principles of Montessori education it's
interesting the Montessori community as
a whole tends to look at the world is
something that needs a central
controller I think if you talk to most
Montessori teachers they're their
political philosophy is very much on the
left and they see the ideas of central
planning is or government involvement is
very necessary but that's not how they
see the classroom the goal of the
teacher according to Maria Montessori
was to become invisible and by that she
means that the student really has to
discover their own capacity and their
own independence as a learner the
mission of the university is to teach
the principles of Liberty what you FM is
also embarking on this I think very
innovative and cutting edge program to
make the student the center of the
classroom to awaken the student to who
they are as learner and to understand
their own learning process
so it just brought together two
philosophies that I think are
hand-in-glove